[Musique]
c'est une route tortueuse si tu veux
serpente à travers monts et vallées une
route qui ne semble pas avoir de fin
performant une route surtout imprégné de
beauté qui perce une nature généreuse
pour dévoiler des paysages somptueux au
lendemain de l' attaque surprise contre
power de la construction d'un lien
routier direct entre l'alaska et le
reste du continent devient une nécessité
quand même réaliseront alors ce qu'on
considère comme l'un des plus grands
accomplissements du génie civil du xxème
siècle construire en moins d'un an
plus de 2000 km de routes en terrain
hostile siècle la route est initialement
réservé à l'usagé exclusif de l'armée
qui l'utilisent pour ravitailler ses
bases aériennes
une fois la guerre finie les yukonnais
se l'approprient rapidement
aujourd'hui on vient des quatre coins du
continent pour vivre l'aventuré et
stoller
c'est magnifique si ces thèmes la nature
la vie sauvage c'est juste comme vierge
aux yeux c'est vraiment des grands
espaces puis c'est vraiment bon
des voyageurs friands de nature et
histoire mais surtout de découvertes sur
[Musique]
les aventuriers en quête de l'ultime
frontière mais peut-être aussi en quête
d'eux mêmes et
[Musique]
l'importante dit on n'est pas la
destination mais le voyage en lui-même
et cani fraudeurs
[Musique]
la citation date ce neuvième siècle mais
elle aurait très bien pu être inspiré
par la route de l'alaska
[Musique]